parce qu'elle Martin sur comment va
s'organiser le débat public sur le
programme nouveau nucléaire et en
particulier le PR2 de ponly donc il
s'ouvre le 27 octobre
il s'ouvre le 27 octobre en fin de
journée
à Dieppe et à Paris la première question
qu'on va mettre en débat d'ailleurs le
27 octobre c'est à quoi sert ce débat
puisque
souvent
nos concitoyens nous disent mais après
tout le président de la République a
fait des déclarations les fameux
discours de Besançon il y a un projet de
loi d'accélération du nucléaire donc
tout est décidé donc c'est pour c'est
pour ça qu'on pose la question de
manière un peu brutale bah d'abord il va
servir à informer la population c'est
quand même important c'est
et surtout il va servir parce que il va
alimenter un débat le vrai décideur
aujourd'hui ça va être le Parlement en
fait c'est quand même une échéance
énorme la loi de programmation énergie
climat donc le vrai décideur c'est le
Parlement donc ce débat il va servir
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui rien n'est
décidé c'est que tout sera décidé au
Parlement pendant l'année 2023
effectivement je doute que ce soit voté
en juillet en juillet 2023 ça semble
difficile donc le débat public a été
séquencé en plusieurs questions il a il
y a 10 questions
il va avoir lieu sur l'ensemble du
territoire national évidemment plus de
réunions en Normandie puisque c'est le
premier territoire concerné mais il y
aura aussi des réunions à Saclay il y
aura aussi des réunions
alors au Tréport oui à Lille à Lyon à
Tours parce que en fait on va pas
simplement mettre en débat la
construction nouveau réacteurs mais tout
ce que ça implique qu'est-ce que ça
implique en amont et ce qu'il faut de
nouvelles
usines d'enrichissement d'uranium
comment est-ce qu'on va s'approvisionner
qu'est-ce que ça implique en aval et ce
qu'il faut une nouvelle piscine encore
une une troisième une piscine à la Hague
et ce qu'il faut est-ce que les
capacités de cigaux sont adaptées donc
on doit effectivement dérouler
l'ensemble de la chaîne mais surtout on
met pas en débat que panli on met aussi
en débat les deux autres paires de
réacteurs qui sont qui sont envisagées
les moyens de participer sont
extrêmement variés il y a bien
évidemment les réunions publiques il y a
des ateliers spécifiques en fonction de
certaines thématiques il y a une
plateforme participative
il y aura probablement des la
possibilité dodo organiser des réunions
locales parce que on veut que le débat
soit très démultiplié sur l'ensemble du
territoire il y a et c'est en cours ce
qu'on appelle une clarification des
controverses il y a certains points de
controverse extrêmement important qui
donc on identifie déjà les points qui
font des accords et on demande aux
experts ceux qui sont pour ceux qui sont
contre sur ces points de désaccord
d'expliquer le pourquoi et on permet
comme ça ça permet de confronter leurs
arguments et de les rendre complément
compréhensible
à tout le monde et puis bien évidemment
il y a une mobilisation des écoles et
des universités pour que
ce débat soit aussi pris en charge et
préemptée par par les jeunes et puis
orage j'imagine des passerelles avec
votre assemblée des votre assemblée des
jeunesse donc 27 octobre 27 février
c'est une durée légale 4 mois on s'est
fixé par le code de l'environnement et
le président du Béna c'est Michel Badré
ça a été le premier président de
l'autorité environnementale et qui a une
qualité incroyable c'est qu'il est
capable de mettre autour de la table les
pour et les contre il est reconnu des
deux il est reconnu par les par les deux
parties
oui je pense que j'ai à peu près tout
dit sur sur ce débat enfin pas tout ce
sera bien plus riche que ce que je vous
ai dit
[Musique]